you're welcome to this video playing
jillian jillian from the philippines
yeah and i'm going with the rugged rang
a tang again can they play some
uncritical line okay yeah well the you
rang a tang is not the most fashionable
opening so people don't have anything
prepared against it I mean it's not that
I have something prepared but i know i
know the critical line with you file and
go for it so let's see at least here
white has quite a decent space there on
the on the queenside let's develop i
wonder if d for as a friend could be
good d for didn't go for it what you see
going for Knight b6 mmm okay let's
prevent that yeah him why it has lots of
space on the queenside whatever you can
say about the opening I just gained
space on the queenside oh it's cute
we're super you're going like a day six
I wonder about queen bee three as well
hey sexy yeah that's that's funny what a
funny position yeah that I thought about
that move and I wasn't sure what to do I
really wasn't
maybe just d3 supporting the center
hmm interesting
okay let's take it
Jim I don't quite get it at the moment
aha okay interesting okay I'm okay if I
go Bishop e2 9f form
yeah come on take the pawn that at least
makes sure so that my bishop won't be
too will have something something to do
in this game and okay so how to go from
here night a4 may be pushing his Bishop
back I wanted to go on a knight to e
form but you prevented that this smooth
maybe yeah 494 yeah Oh Bishop a3 the
right moment let's go here
yep I have to activate that Bishop them
looking at the rukon the ADA that I can
go rook c8 probably know what is this
some fancy tactic here let's what is
this I don't get it ok Bishop f2 I am
you can also take here check what is the
point there we can go Bishop takes 24
next
I know maybe I could have taken that but
I don't I don't know check here so 97 or
97 wins wins material there's no no
particular reason not to take it this is
probably better I know I don't know
what's better
yeah if he now they cannot easily go to
c5 with the night one important point is
that my advanced pawns can be very very
dangerous there with Lexi five this
breakthrough can become very dangerous
yeah the orangutan I have one hundred
percent score with that in blitz chess I
played one game earlier in the session
and one and this one and it also looks
good it's not winning but it looks good
can I take on deform why not exactly
let's take it it's an important point so
my back rank is weak definitely but at
the moment I don't see how we might use
that night is hanging so big fancy but
the ruckus is good only on the e-file
here rook e8 wait rook da droopy 657
group takes g6 and then be success
winning so that's a good good way to
simplify as I said that the points that
are dangerous
black resigned yeah yeah the problem is
he takes takes oops he takes it and c5
and that's it yeah be six tix should be
seven and resins now that that is the
decisive factor the early porn push
there was some paving the way for that
yeah again the rang a tang this is
should be panel equal maybe my test
swatch has some space there on the
queenside okay 97 okay what what is the
comp giving the cop is giving d4 here
yeah I have this suspicion now you know
that this might be right my whites
whites position is a bit it's a bit
uncoordinated but but I absolutely did
not see the point I was just thinking
maybe here and now I don't know it was
kind of unclear in my mind but here this
is the engine suggestion this is really
strong very nice move trying to open up
the e-file very strong like this and I
have to go back and now black has an has
an excellent oops an excellent attack I
would have been very strong this this
and probably again yeah d 5 is again
good d 4 he went here yeah it's the same
idea this is again strong this is what
you played and I'm trying to kept it and
keep it close now yeah so I snatched
that okay the end chest giving that was
headed okay interesting interesting
Pusha p.m.
computer gives white a big advantage but
I have doubts I really doubt that it
looks very dangerous for white probably
the compass writer and it usually is in
this kind of sharp position but it's
something where you as you play your
kind of afraid but I get castle xenium
him until yeah why it is probably a bit
better but it's a very very complicated
thing here here here the engine just
takes here and says black is good I am
the engines has this move that is good
here but I'm not actually here the line
that the computer is giving is quite
interesting this this check check okay
this is good for black ok i am misread
that actually i thought i thought there
was a different position where i keep
the pawns them no damn that was good
then from blanket was a very murky murky
a part of this game here I'm much better
so it probably has to go like somewhere
else this is interesting check we having
dance are there are many possibilities
after that I think white is really just
better sorry rookie three SS is a good
move i think we don't have much else
anyway and after that winds down red
wins Knight e5 was tougher I expected
that I wanted to take and then then I
didn't know exactly what to expect this
was my idea but I didn't calculate
further an important idea is always that
in many situations I might be able to
return the return the exchange and go
from here the point is that those those
pawns there they are so dangerous yeah
for example okay again that's very help
this is this is again a breakthrough
yeah they don't play some some
aggressive line against one before so
I'm getting away with it okay well
thanks for watching